si madame la parole et comme c'est
bernard gérard merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre en
plein état d'urgence
le président de la république jette
l'épongé il est en cessation progressive
d'activité
le premier ministre manuel valls est
parti et monsieur maquereau a quant à
lui abandonné son poste de ministre de
l'économie curieuse gestion d'une
situation critique
pourtant à vous entendre tout va bien
pour le président de la république tout
va mieux
lors de votre discours de politique
générale vous avez même pas un tableau
quasi idyllique de la situation de la
france mais sur le plan économique il y
à un sujet dont vous vous gardez bien de
parler et qui est pourtant
particulièrement grave et inquiétant
monsieur le premier ministre
soyez sincère quelle est la situation
réelle des entreprises à participation
publique
allez vous encore une fois nous cacher
la vérité qu'en est-il monsieur le
premier ministre de la situation
financière exacte de la sncf dont la
branche réseaux accuse une dette de 44
milliards d'euros qu'en est-il monsieur
le premier ministre d'areva qui connaît
des pertes qui se chiffrent en milliards
d'euros dernier exercice connu
plus inquiétant encore qu'en est-il
réellement de la situation d'edf
la presse s'est fait écho la semaine
dernière d'une situation catastrophique
et d'un passif qui pourrait s'établir à
hauteur de 74 milliards d'euros monsieur
le premier ministre vous devez la vérité
à la représentation nationale
vous devez ici préciser clairement
quelle est la situation exacte de ces
entreprises à participation publique et
quel est le plan le plan d'action que
vous allez mettre en oeuvre pour
remettre remédier à ces situations de
quasi faillite
qu'avez-vous à cacher monsieur le
premier ministre quel est le montant de
l'ars d'oise que les françaises et les
français vont devoir régler pour faire
face à l'incurie de l'état socialiste la
parole octobre michel sapin ministre de
l'économie et des finances
c'est monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur député
gérard vous aborder des sujets qui sont
sérieux un quine date pas d'aujourd'hui
nos entreprises publiques à majorité de
capitaux publics sont là depuis quelques
années parfois même depuis 1945 et
l'abordé sur un ton polémique totalement
inutile et qui rabaisse dans la manière
dont les choses sont perçus à
l'extérieur le sérieux de votre question
vraiment pourquoi mais pourquoi parler
ainsi pourquoi polémiquer ainsi sur des
entreprises publiques qui par ailleurs
représente une chance pour notre pays
une chose pour notre économie
une chance pour notre société si edf
aujourd'hui a besoin de l'attention du
gouvernement
est-ce que cela date franchement
franchement est ce que ça vaut ce genre
d'interpellations est ce que vous croyez
que si edf aujourd'hui a besoin de la
tension du gouvernement et y compris le
gouvernement s'y est engagée à une
recapitalisation
c'est parce que au cours de ces derniers
mois où de ces dernières années il y
aurait eu des événements qui auraient
pesé sur l'avenir de der si areva
aujourd'hui a besoin non seulement de la
tension mais d'un travail extrêmement
précis extrêmement concret de
reconstruction de la filière nucléaire
ce serait à cause de ces dernières
semaines vous avez laissé la filière
nucléaire française dans un état
lamentable et nous devons aujourd'hui la
réparer progressivement de même que vous
avez laissé la sncf dans un état tant
d'errements auquel nous devons
aujourd'hui faire face
vos cris ne servent à rien vos
interpellations et les interruptions
change rien à la réalité des choses
les entreprises publiques françaises
sont une chance
le gouvernement est à leurs côtés et je
veux d'abord et avant tout rendre
hommage à ceux qui les dirigent à ceux
qui travaillent qui sont une richesse
pour la france
merci monsieur le ministre